une proposition de loi pour mieux
protéger les lanceurs d'alertés étudié
aujourd'hui à l'assemblée un texte et
ambitionne de faire référence au niveau
européen les états unis réclament
toujours et de nouveaux l'extradition de
julian assange au royaume uni hier dès
les parlementaires français se sont
mobilisés pour offrir l'asile politique
au fondateur de wikileaks
pour les plus de précision va retrouver
notre reporter nadège abderrazak
[Musique]
bonjour la vaige c'est donc une
proposition de loi du député modem
sylvain wasserman qui va être examiné
aujourd'hui en première lecture à
l'assemblée nationale
absolument le texte qui vise à renforcer
la protection des lanceurs d'alerté veut
aller plus loin que la loi pionnière
dans ce domaine la loi sapin 2 de 2016 à
la veille de la présidence française de
l'union européenne au 1er janvier cette
proposition de loi ambitionne aussi
d'être une référence au niveau européen
en allant au delà d'une directive de
bruxelles de 2019 qu'elle retranscrit
alors du scandale du médiator dans
l'industrie pharmaceutique au luxe l'x
os x l'x sur le monde de la finance et
des affaires retentissantes ont à
plusieurs reprises a montré le combat
difficile des lanceurs d'alert
et puis l'adage et dans les grandes
lignes que prévoit le texte pour la
défense de ces lanceurs dallaire
justement
alors magali à la proposition de loi
prévoit de mieux définir le statut des
lanceurs d'alerté d'orienter leurs
démarches mieux les protéger faciliter
leur soutien financier et psychologique
entre autres l'une des principales
dispositions
elle prévoit la suppression de la notion
jugée ambiguë de désintéressement du
lanceur d' alerte qui le met par exemple
en difficulté en cas de recours pour
obtenir des indemnités devant les
prud'hommes cette notion serait
remplacée par celle de sans contrepartie
financière directe le défenseur des
droits aussi on aura un rôle crucial à
jouer celui d'orienter le lanceur d'
alerte vers le bon canal et si
nécessaire rendre lui-même un avis pour
savoir si l'auteur d'un signalement peut
se prévaloir de la qualité de lanceur
d'alert la proposition de loi prévoit
aussi
des sanctions à l'encontre de ceux qui
divulguerait contre son gré l identité
d'un lanceur d' alerte ou chercheraient
à étouffer son action sous des pressions
procédure abusive ou à lui faire subir
des représailles alors c'est dans ce
contexte quand vous l'avez dit qu'une
quarantaine de députés de tous bords ont
signé une résolution hier pour que
julian assange obtiennent l'asile
politique en france le journaliste
lanceur d'alert fondateur de wikileaks
est actuellement toujours incarcérés
dans la prison britannique de belmarsh
et il encourt une peine de 100 75 ans si
en cas d'extradition vers les états unis
pour avoir divulgué des centaines de
milliers de documents classifiés sur les
agissements de l'armée américaine en
afghanistan et en irak notamment merci
beaucoup de neige pour toutes ces
précisions on a déjà des razak en direct
devant l'assemblée nationale à paris